hi Helen my name is anthony from say and
i'm the managing director for cisco in
North Africa and the Levant and I just
loved your question it was a very good
question because why going through
education is at the end of the day you
don't know how to be measured by its ok
i thought it's a very good question and
personally i believe and probably not
surprisingly that the internet can
actually help a lot of it that type of
standardization of education and
measuring and monitoring it so that
there is an equal opportunity for
everybody to be measured against the
standardized set of talents so i think
personally it's a very very good
question i believe that internet
technology can help in that area of
course it is important to have the right
online material the content but also the
way to to get the content to the
students around the world so that they
can be compared and monitored in in an
automated way again I'm just like to
close off with one little remark
although I managing director Francisco
I'm also by education I'm a teacher and
that's why I loved your questions so
much really good question thanks and
keep it up bye-bye